hello and welcome to maths implied in
this video we will look at the top five
myths about the coronavirus myth number
one the virus will die off when
temperatures rise in the spring well yes
some viruses such as the cold and flu
viruses do spread more easily in colder
months but that does not mean that they
stop entirely when conditions become
warmer as it stands scientists do not
know how temperature changes will
influence the behavior of coronavirus
myth number two Karara virus is the
deadliest virus known to man
this statement is untrue over nineteen
is only fatal for a small percentage of
population in a recent report the
Chinese Center for Disease Control
concluded that eighty point nine percent
of the phobic cases were mild the WHI
also reported that around eighty percent
of the people will experience a
relatively mild form of the disease
which will not require specialist
treatment in hospital although corona
virus does appear to be more serious
than influenza it is not the deadliest
virus that people have faced others such
as Ebola have higher mortality rates
myth number three cats and dogs spread
coronavirus at present there is no
evidence that animals or pets such as
dogs and cats can be infected with a new
corona virus however there has been a
case report of a cat being tested weekly
positive for corona virus after
contracting it from his owner but it is
always a good idea to wash your hands
with soap and water after contact with
pets myth number four antibiotics and
home remedies kill corona virus
antibiotics can only kill bacteria they
are not effective against viruses at
present there is no evidence that any
home remedy can protect against over
nineteen the best approach is to adopt a
good hand-washing regime and to avoid
crowded places
if there is anything that can protect
you from coronavirus is your own
immunity watch our video series on the
topic of immunity and healthy lifestyle
changes you can do to boost your
immunity myth number five the virus was
engineered by China in a lab despite
thousands of internet rumors there is no
evidence that this is the case in fact a
recent study demonstrates that the virus
is a natural product of evolution some
researchers believe that coronavirus may
have jumped from pangolins to humans
others think that it might have passed
to us from bats which was the same case
for SARS Scripps Research Institute
which is an American medical research
facility said that the corona virus is
not a laboratory construct or a
purposefully manipulated virus we can
firmly determine that corona virus
originated through natural processes
however Chinese authorities have been
blamed for allowing the virus to spread
as far as if did by suppressing the news
about the initial spread and downplaying
its transmission on December 31 the
Wuhan government made its first official
announcement that 27 people had fallen
ill to a mysterious virus that appeared
from a seafood market but it denied that
the virus can be transmitted from human
to human this was a crucial factor which
would have differentiated more easily
controllable illnesses from full-blown
epidemics
it wasn't until January 23 weeks after
Vaughn's first announcement that the
human to human transmission was
confirmed who Hans Mayer later took
responsibility for the delay and said
his hands were tied by the central
party's rule after I receive information
I can only release it when I'm
authorized he said a national law
dictates that the local governments can
only declare an epidemic after receiving
approval from the Chinese Communist
Party China's social media pages have
been flooded with angry citizens
criticizing officials for failing to
contain the initial outbreak in the
lockdown city much of the anger was
because authorities initially suppress
the information of the outbreak what are
your thoughts about this topic let's
discuss in the comments below I hope you
liked the video see you in the next one